- Russian radiation monitoring stations
have resumed operation and this news
follows a number of alarming reports
that were made earlier by a number of
foreign news media claiming that several
Russian radiation monitoring stations
went offline allegedly after a nuclear
accident that happened in Russia's north
on August the 8th The Wall Street
Journal wrote that four stations that
were designed to detect nuclear
radiation all went silent right after
the blast the article raised concerns
that Russia was attempting to conceal
evidence from the explosion at a missile
test site The Wall Street Journal quoted
latinas Arabo the executive director of
the comprehensive nuclear-test-ban
organization which receives data from
monitoring stations around the world now
he projected the potential path of the
plume from the explosion and posted it
on his Twitter feed now right after the
accident Russia sent special experts to
the site to monitor the situation and
just yesterday the country's President
Vladimir Putin said that there was no
threat of a radiation leak there is no
threat there and there's no spike in
radiation levels experts at the site
including independent ones are
monitoring the situation I receive
reports from both military and civilian
specialists and there's no significant
change there but we are still taking
precautionary measures to avoid any
surprises now first right after the
accident there were indeed very few
details available on what happened and
that mostly fueled Western tabloids so
whether rumors of a Chernobyl like
disaster whispers of a radiation leak
also appeared in the media with some
even writing about the number of the
deceased being higher now later the
Russian nuclear agency issued a report
revealing that the accident happened on
a sea platform after a series of trials
and that there was no threat of a
radiation leak
you